[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
avec laurent mazaury bonsoir bonsoir à
vous attend au maire d'elancourt vous
êtes le président de tv 70 vite monsieur
le président merci de nous recevoir chez
moi ça me fait bien plaisir
on essaie vous les ors du parti jean
baptiste duclair soyez polis avec
monsieur le président on m'a prévenue et
déjà mais ça me rappelle qui plus est
autant vous dire tout de suite et jean
baptiste du père vous enseignez toujours
à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin exactement 3
public à jordan bezina bonjour bonsoir
vous êtes enseignant aussi de droit
public et de science politique à
sciences po et à l'université de rouen
exactement et jean charles lajoie dit
soit vous êtes éditeur toujours et et on
va profiter de vos deux dernières
parutions voilà val dernière en date pas
de manière non non pas mais je continue
après alors le sicilien carpino c'est un
auteur absolument épatant kapinos bala
non mais c'est vrai c'est beaucoup mieux
c'est pas pinot simple flic c'est non et
s'écarte pineau grands auteurs non c'est
une trilogie qui se passe à 90 et sur
trois années ces trois décennies
différentes dans les années 80 et 90 et
des années 2000
et ça c'est des années 90 donc
passionnant est vraiment époustouflant
et un autre alors ça ça s'appelle le
sicilien
voilà il ya les guinéens qui est juste
avant hier radiation un radiation sa c2
de paul perreault alors palmeiro et le
prix du quai des orfèvres
voilà il ya
voilà et qui était un ancien flic il est
toujours il est toujours c'est le shérif
de toulouse
ah d'accord ah oui parce que j'ai
souvent des anciens flics lui il est
toujours environnement dans le vide et
il est toujours en activité et ça se
passe bien que la police avait de la
hiérarchie poli mais fessiers ça se
passe très bien il ya un autre exemple
jean marc souvira que commissaire
divisionnaire il écrit des livres qui
sont vachement bien et c'est pas chez
eux c'est pas de la pub s'est passé moi
hélas ces mots creux c'est mon cousin il
est passé comme chez moi palmero enfin
bref épaulera glisse voilà il est
toujours dans la police ça se passera
bien voilà est hélas c'est un son
deuxième disque frenchy malgré le
retrait du du quai des orfèvres est un
roman qui mêle espionnage intrigue
policière et on démarre ap
dans la région de fukushima au japon et
on arrive jusqu'à paris avec des
terroristes auprès duquel les terrorise
le secteur n'ont rien à envier enfin
parce que là il ya des lots démarre par
une scène absolument mais hallucinante
et abracadabrantesque dans le marché
dans les sous sols de tokyo mais
j'espère que le héros radiation est bien
parti et et se rappelle quand même le
sicilien de kalkar minot voilà deux très
bon livre pour l'été pour les vacances
alors on est en pleine saison du baht
week est sûre vous souvenir
il y en a qui sont très brillants parmi
nous non ils ont dû passer comme ça les
doigts dans le nez
mais question vous souvenir du bac vous
pouvez même pas en parler parce qu'elle
a eu son bac à 14 mentions très bien
qu'est-ce qu'on va rajouter après cinq à
14 on essayait d'avoir le bepc souvenir
qui est totalement réhabilité puisque
j'habitais à l'époque à paris dans le
19ème arrondissement et y avait une
grève mais c'était pas les airs fait
seul nom salaires atp a donc j'étais
parti à pied du 19e arrondissement
jusque dans le xiiième ce qu'à l'époque
qu'elle n'est pas un jour sans traîner
comme un examen à l'opposé et donc
j'avais découvert paris en marchant
pendant trois heures pour arriver aux
vagues dans un d'état évidemment pour
l'épreuve de maths qui était loin d'être
satisfaisant voyez les grèves étaient
déjà là on parlait de la grève jean
baptiste est votre souvenir sujet en
histoire mais c'est parce qu'il a marqué
c'était plutôt une étudiante qui était à
main droite et qui m'a posé une question
pendant l'épreuve en devenant ckoi
l'ataraxie donc moi j'avais un cas de
conscience parce que ce que je lui
répondais est ce que j'aurai désagrégea
l'ataraxie c'est vrai c'est un bonheur
l'on prolongé s'inscrit dans l'eau mais
du coup c'est à dire un cas de
conscience
c'est pas très sympa oui le souvenir que
j'en ai vu c'était plutôt comme ça
pourquoi si tôt pour des raisons voilà
d'âge qui n'avançait pas c'est à dire
qu'en fait j'avais sauté tellement de
classe au primaire que du combat je suis
à 14 ans au bac et ça a été avec une
mention très bien j'étais la plus jeune
mention très bien et nancy ont été reçus
à l'elysée voilà c'était la petite heure
cette équipe c'était jacques chirac à
l'époque oui alors bon c'est georges
pompidou l'aurais pas cru
c'est vincent auriol
c'est vincent si super 14 en corse et
qui s'est déjà comme 3 et goudjo partir
à la chasse n'est pas réussi à avoir mon
bac avec un en bas tu vois là et c'était
pas une section très sympa de la part de
l'examinateur ne pas avoir mis zéro qui
est quand même un truc quasiment tout ça
parce que maintenant quand je donne des
cours à tous j'ai toujours présenter un
truc propre et jolie ou un même si c'est
nul
au moins vous avez une chance d'avoir le
point qui fait que c'est pas dramatique
voix et c'est pour ça que j'aime bien je
pense que je n'avais rien à dire sur le
zinc parfois on rattrape
je ne sais pas si vous arrivez des des
copies en droit notamment de gens dont
on se dit ils savent rien mais c'est
plutôt il ya un peu d'humour il ya un
peu de choses comme ça on peut donner si
cette non ça peut le droit laisse pas
beaucoup place à l'humour mais je suis
malheureusement je vois j'ai une très
bonne copie on a eu 1 17 en droit
constitutionnel sur quelqu'un qui avait
commencé par une phrase de oss 117 qui
était quand même très improbable mais
qui était complètement dans le sujet
puisque c'était la phrase où justement
cet agent dit est ce que vous connaissez
un état où il n'y a qu'une seule télé
une seule personnalité qui dominent le
monde et dit oui la vème république
général de bull j'avais trouvé ça c'est
une phrase d'accroché en effet assez
voilà donc comme l'humour que parfois il
peut mettre une phrase d'audiard mes
enfants copie de philo les cons ça ose
tout c'est même à ça qu'on les reconnaît
et bah ça m'avait pas plu du bac
très beau vin dont je joue pas j'aimais
pas ça moi je vais passer un bureau mais
bon mais non je me suis plus amusé après
qu' il y avait des matières qui
m'embêtait mois dans le secondaire et
des matières que je n'ai pas la techno
oui enfin les noms des sciences
naturelles décision arrange pas laisser
visionner match mais voilà on a tous eu
une vraie question c'est utile alors
avant de dire sa musique vous vous
disiez estimant qu'il y avait une grève
l'année vous avez passé le battre là il
y avait encore des profs qui qui qui
faisaient grève j'entendais hier qu'ils
étaient interrogés disaient oui si on
fait grève c'est pour le bien des élèves
et des parents
je ne suis pas très sûr que les parents
et les élèves ont trouvé cela formidable
pas ce jour 6 impasse et je dis donc ça
semble que oui mais enfin on est souvent
tendance à utiliser cela comme remy à
résister après il n'en demeure pas moins
que les professeurs aujourd'hui sont pas
assez payés en france contre ils
comparaissent dans l'europe
ça c'est une réalité par contre quand on
prend le vrai sujet de la réforme
c'était pas du tout sujet ça impacte
part réellement les professeurs en
réalité c'est un impact plutôt les
collectivités territoriales et entre
autres les communes où on va aller au
conseil départemental aussi puisque
c'est ce qui se cache un petit peu d'air
ce taux était c'est un transfert de
compétences avec un transfert de de
gestion et de charges sont anciens
budgétaire mais très ennuyant pour les
familles des spectacles mais c'est ce
qui se passait sur fond de la réforme
et ça n'impacte pas le travail des
précédents qui paiera le personnel
médical sociale inégalités qui n'aurait
pas existé à partir du moment où c'est
une
charge qui est à la charge de l'état
puisque du coup quand c'est une
collectivité territoriale ça dépend du
budget de la collectivité
ajoutons aussi que du coup ça rajoute en
effet aux dépenses obligatoires et donc
nécessairement un nouvel impact sur le
budget des collectivités dont on avait
déjà parlé qui sont plus ou moins atone
en ce moment donc dont si je prends
l'exemple d'elancourt où j'ai le plaisir
d'être maire-adjoint nous avions une
dotation générale maryse la culture
chargé de la culture et les loisirs
je tiens beaucoup les wasaï nous avions
dotation générale de fonctionnement en
2014 qui étaient 1 5 million 6 cette
année nous sommes amis ont cinq regards
que l'état a baissé à 10 4 me nommer
vous rendez compte voilà qu'elle revient
en cinq années tout en y rajoutant
évidemment des vrais charges et donc
celles ci sont des charges
supplémentaires que je ne serai pas
comment financer amender la seule
manière plus avant de le financer à part
les économies qu'on peut peut-être
encore éventuellement faire en baissant
les prestations pour les concitoyens
c'est d'augmenter les impôts la boucle
est bouclée on n'a pas de capacité
augmente aujourd'hui des impôts sur des
gens qui gagnent de moins en moins que
sont plus en plus chargé par conséquent
ce transfert de charges là s'il n'est
pas financée par état n'est pas
acceptable et on va au bout et comme
l'état surendetté évidemment il ne paye
que financée par la dette supplémentaire
mais les la boucle est bouclée anticipé
la baisse d'élèves de croyez vous ah oui
parce que ça va être de devenir une
denrée rare
les élèves sur l employé pas de gaz elle
elle parce que la cause est la
démographie louis 9 ans à peine
c'est vrai tout ou de tous les âges et
pour le coup enfin julien on sait très
bien que dans 20 ans je vais y aura plus
de profs que des et puis c'est possible
non mais tant qu une question nationale
sera ça un peu comme le ministère de
l'agriculture où il ya plus de
fonctionnaires que l'agriculture
oui mais vous dites ça mais est il
possible d'échapper au temps l'a10 a
commencé par la philo est elle possible
d'échapper au temps on aimerait bien il
ya des sujets je boudais site est il
possible d'échapper au temps à quoi bon
explique une oeuvre d'art reconnaître
ses devoirs et seront annoncés à sa
liberté ne le travail difficile des
hommes la morale et l mais la meilleure
politique il ya un sujet qui vous aurait
tenté c'est toujours compliqué morale et
politique est politique c'est vrai
c'était parce que qu'est-ce que c'est la
morale qu'est ce que c'est le meilleur
politique qu'est ce que c'est aussi
celle de choses dans celui ci parce que
vous n'êtes pas obligé d'être uniquement
dans le cadre académique de citer des
philosophes comme on attend aussi d'une
copie de philo mais vous êtes aussi un
petit peu dans l'actualité politique
finalement donc il ya pas mal de de
matière à développer moi je ne trouvais
pas mal mais c'était quand même qu'elles
ont peu existé à restaurer peut citer
platon on peut citer aussi toute la
doctrine du savoir finalement est-ce
qu'il faut être un sachant est-ce qu'il
faut être un et puis même un homme mon
pour être un homme politique et qu'est
ce que c'est que la politique ce qui est
déjà le cas
les russes il relève peut-être beaucoup
plus de la religion que de la politique
la politique va de la morale dont je ne
crois pas on doit être morale en
politique de la politique pour
transcrire un acte moral c'est à lattes
avant que je suis un sujet j'aurais
adoré donné en première année droit
parce qu'en fait on a une multiplication
des législations morale endroit qui mois
pour moi me semble totalement hors des
clous du droit et du droit surtout des
transpositions % d'accord il doit être
su si on a une séparation des églises et
de l'état c'est pas pour traiter de la
morale en matière de droit même si on
veut pas juger en droit mais le sujet
peut se renverser parce que sida à la
morale on met des infections du type il
ne faut pas dire ceci
d'ailleurs cela il faut parler des
femmes comme ceux ci et c'est que du
coup on a le sentiment qu'on peut plus
rien dire
ça peut être dangereux parce que je
trouve qu'on a un discours très
moralisateur mais qui peut aussi porter
une atteinte parfois excessive à la
liberté d'expression des seuls faux il
faut évidemment être mesuré dans la rep
ont dû sortir partie la bonne
organisation
je pense effectivement qui élit son bac
tout le monde qui a fait son service
militaire
vous êtes deux c'est beau j'ai fait ma
journée d'appel national à la défense à
l'époque ça avait déjà changé et nous
c'est comme charles à la peine à la des
voyages en aides appelle moi ça a duré
une journée
exemple j'ai respecté tout moment
sujet verbe complément on va demander de
me parler
les trois humains et donc le service
militaire et déjà été supprimée
l'entente oui c'était sous le même
président que c'est pas le citer de noms
mais voilà c'est pas la meilleure chose
que le président chirac et c'est
probablement là c'est ce qu'il ya de
pire au monde ce qu'il a fait pire au
monde en ruine et la france des petites
villes qui ne vivaient que de ça c'est
un point aussi
cazères catastrophe a plu
du coup les jaccottet de l'argent non
mais s'inquiétait de la rentrée des
classes pour la défense assure louise
aborde les questions
alors d'abord c'est la réponse c'est oui
ou non mais la défense nationale se
professionnalise et doris et volare
jeunes session me laisse parler je dois
parler dans cette édition c'était non
mais ça a vidé les canadiennes qui tombe
en ruine
les commerces ont fermé tout alentour et
c'est donc l'argent économisé d'un côté
on a perdu au décuple à côté d'un donne
dans les régions c'est une catastrophe
ça c'est de la prévention argent
réceptacle aux siens lors il était
apprécié alors tout le monde n'a qu'un
mot à la bouche et le lien social le
mélange des cultures ça sert à ça c'est
totalement terminée tant que jamais
alors que moi j'ai rencontré pendant mes
classes service militaire noté jean
jaurès jamais imaginé un jour ça
existait oui c'est bon c'est vrai que
c'est ce qu'on a le brassage social
c'est dire que tu es contre
l'illettrisme parce que je vous parlais
tout à l'heure on m'a appelé sujet bien
documenté d'être aigres et bien sûr
je promets à lire à écrire à la hausse
avec michel souvient de sa vie il ya
même des débris des gens qui sont venus
après un peu des mêmes des intellos
alors qu'ils savaient pas lire c'était
des débouchés professionnels des gens se
disaient que je ne sais rien faire donc
je vais rester je vais rester dans
l'armée parce que j'ai trouvé ma voie
c'était étonnant aujourd'hui tout le
monde apprenait on exactement c'est pas
toujours d'après à fumer demande
approuvée à bord a aussi d'autres choses
qu'on ne s'est pas vrai on savait déjà
les troupes s'est déroulée puisque on
met le paquet de troupes
et puis il y avait aussi ce que ce qu'on
a oublié complètement c'était la
détection médical ses supporters
convoyer si les gens étaient miro pamir
aussi les deux grandes banques s'étaient
massés à c'était extraordinaire
tout le monde passer la main c'est
surtout sur la question on parle
beaucoup des femmes en ce moment on
parle peut-être un petit peu moins des
hommes et c'est vrai que je crois que à
ces époques là le caractère militaire
donne quand même une je crois un courage
une peur des événements aussi qui
n'existe plus avec un journée d'appel à
la défense qu'on fait planqué comme vous
dites dans un établissement où tout va
bien et il y avait quand même ce côté
défense nationale cette militarisation
qui donnait aussi un sens de l'autorité
de la discipline de voile a finalement
capoté limitèrent vaut peut-être on peut
refaire toujours le passé mais enfin la
plupart des gens qui étaient appelés au
service militaire n'avait qu'un rêve
c'était d'y échapper quand même mais
n'ont pas pris beaucoup du mal moi le
premier j'aurai donc échappé parce que
ça arrive à des mauvais moment parce que
ça pouvait se repenser parce que ça
c'est la libye qu'on nous a toujours
donné on peut réorganiser les choses
pour qu'il dure peut-être un peu moins
longtemps qu' un petit peu plus de sens
prendre en compte des années
d'incorporation en fonction des
magiciens professionnels fallu modifier
on pouvait le modifier ça pouvait
vraiment rentrer dans les cases et moi
je vais bien nous l'ont bien au delà de
ça je vais dans le sens de ce que vous
disiez je pense qu'il fallait l'étendre
aux femmes c'est que la vérité du sujet
a été pour en être un vrai creuset
républicain de réduire la durée et de
l'étendre à l'ensemble de la population
elle veut jouer au foot qu'elle faisait
dans l'armée je l'attendais des grands
exemples de deux démocraties dans le
monde sombre en israël alors ok c'est la
déconfiture de la mondialisation
néanmoins rationnelle à travers la
professionnalisation mais moi je suis
plutôt dans l'aspect républicain des
choses et dans l'aspect 100 % de la
population à un moment donné pendant un
certain temps
tu vis la même chose premier de la même
façon on détecte les mêmes
problématiques
et quelque part on crée un sentiment
d'appartenance aujourd'hui quel est le
sentiment d'appartenance à la république
à la nation
quand on semble écoles des gens pas dans
les mêmes écoles vous parliez tout à
l'heure de différentes façons brassage
il ya plus brassage social on est dans
des pays quand ce n'est pas parce qu'on
est avec son téléphone
sociaux qu'on s'ouvre plus au monde au
contraire ans ferme alors peut-être que
je vais dire un gros mot savez je conte
de dire ça mais je reste intimement
persuadé que c'était le moment
républicain par excellence c'était
service militaire il aurait fallu leur
pensée on aurait pu faire des économies
sans qu'effectivement ça et là c'est les
régions entières et des villes parce
qu'on aurait par exemple réduit la durée
ne l'est plus de sens y aurait eu autant
de gens dans les contingents un peu
moins longtemps mais des villes et nos
différentes caisses d'un n'aurait pas
fermé
je pense que cette idée là est encore
venue d'une double problématique d'avoir
une forme de morale parce que quelque
part on avait gardé une mauvaise image
de notre armée elle avait une mauvaise
image parce qu'on était issu de 14-18 de
77 40 dans lequel on en voit
effectivement de gens à l'abattoir face
à des chars et donc voit le plan de
contingence et c'était les poitrines
n'avait pas d'intérêt
ça ses premiers points mais derrière se
cache et encore une fois la même chose
que tout à l'heure une réalité de
volonté qui était purement économique
avec une erreur de type hainard c'est à
dire que furent une économie parce que
supprime temps des personnes alors qu'on
en était l'impact sur le perso et entre
autres on parle aujourd'hui de gilet
jaune et on parle de la province je
comprends votre point c'était un des
points aussi lu du cimetière et en
europe
les essais mais fallait l'améliorer mais
perfectible c'est justement s'est pas
améliorée parce que si c'est au service
militaire qu'on apprend le brassage
social et qu'on apprend à écrire à
parler à compter c'est très insultant
pour les cônes républicaine je pense que
le vrai problème c'est année c'est la
réforme de l'école rideau et ben
justement il faut créer les conditions
pour que les gens soient plus sortir
d'un système qui justement ne leur ouvre
plus les portes ou qui décourage les
jeunes et pour moi il faut que le
service militaire permettent à la france
de préparer une défense en cas d'
attaques ont respectivement il ya pas eu
de guerre très très importante depuis la
suppression du service militaire donc
d'une certaine manière on a fait des
économies et c'est un pari qui a été
emporté voilà exactement mais je pense
que pour moi le vrai sujet c'est la
réforme de l'école est de faire que
quand on est contre on sort de cette
école on se sente l'égal de l'autre et
que l'on sache parler écrire et compter
mais quand leur ont majoré par exemple
le disiez au fond c'est plus très bien
ce que c'est que la france est
aujourd'hui enfin est ce que vous pensez
peut-être
ces photos républicain pat le rêve de
beckham non mais c'est peut-être un
raccourci car par exemple moins de
jeunes qui erraient vers le djihad s'il
y avait les services militaires
sûrement parce que ce qu'on voit de les
gens qui vont vers le jazz il ya quand
même beaucoup de témoignages voulait on
voit bien que soi-disant les jeunes
n'auraient pas besoin de règles alors
qu'en fait ce qu'ils vont chercher là
bas aussi ce sont des règles lorsqu'il
arrive là-bas l'unir c'est au delà de du
tout c'est militer c'est vraiment car
est donc bien bien et on voit le club et
ses nus qui viennent des bars et les
premiers témoignages sont absolument
épatant enfin et battant après on aime
ou on n'aime pas mais et tous les jeunes
sont en train d bah oui faut se lever à
telle heure au machin on a besoin d'eux
et il y avait un témoignage sur france
inter d'un d'un gamin de 16 ans que
saison et me dire non mais moi ça me
fait du bien mais j'avais besoin de ce
truc on cadre un peu je retrouve des
choses et bien parce qu'effectivement
peut-être que ses parents n'étaient pas
en possibilité de le faire et clairement
tout cas c'est bien c'est vrai qu'il ya
des moments où on peut avoir besoin d'un
cadre était ne laisse que justement la
ceni répond à vos questions vous posiez
c'est-à-dire brassage social il a fait
ses courses dans la société civile
emmanuel macron et pris un engagement
c'est sur la base du volontariat
bon an mal an la crise est pour
l'instant et puis si simple on voulait
endiguer pas qu'on gèle mais je veux pas
non plus pour vous répondre sur internet
s'était pas opposé les choses c'est là
que pour moi c'est pas parce que des
services militaires que cercueil
forcément du chef de l'école c'était
permettent de détecter effectivement des
situations d'échec ce qui ne nous
empêche pas de devoirs quand même
refaire réformer l'école et constater
aujourd'hui et j'ai tendance à dire
attention à cette tendance qu'on aurait
fait la même chose justement avec le
scolaire c'est-à-dire en fait à dire à
un moment donné on va arrêter les
enfants plutôt à la rue en extra je
pense que ce risque là il existe
aujourd'hui dans l'école mais que c'est
pas pour autant qu'on n'aurait pas pu
quand même conserver un service
militaire qui était le filtre ultime
j'allais dire un petit peu quand tout a
échoué wild qui remplissait un rôle
et pour le coup je reviens sur la morale
qui pouvait être la morale que l'école
après tout n'est pas aujourd'hui en
mission de donner voilà même si je suis
d'accord elle devrait elle devrait être
le creuset républicain délégation la
troisième république avait bien un
problème d'autorité aussi du point de
vue du corps professoral puis fait que
justement
paris le service ouais c'est vraiment
moi qui fais vieux con sociaux non
médecins de nostalgie qu'il affiche
mais vous ne l'avez pas connu non pas
pour les institutions leur
fonctionnement mais en tout cas pour
certains c'est l'école publique et
l'école républicaine non sa grandeur si
je puis dire tant le professeur que le
parent est vrai que le coq
l'instituteur et en blouse grise il
était respecté en la plume monsieur
n'arrivait pas en jeans et en tongs pour
faire son cours il aurait fallu qu'il a
un ministre était de 10
pour faire court on peut avoir une tenue
à peu près des centres mais je devais me
lancer pas message s'est passé quand
vous dites ça aujourd'hui on ne vous dit
tout de suite mais c'est sûr on brûle en
fait puisqu'on parle de zdar mais on va
pas les uniformes et moi je suis pour
mettre des uniformes à l'école dans un
seul but ses coûts comme les différences
aussi choisi moi je veux pas savoir si
mon le petit voisin d'à côté les riches
et les pauvres et je trouve que alors
uniforme caricature mais dans 80% des
écoles du monde aujourd'hui des
éléphants pour les l'afrique qu'elle
défende quasiment tous les pays
africains
et alors et pour autant ces sont des
pays forcément dictatoriaux
antirépublicain on a une espèce de peur
henry t on ont souvent servi fierté bien
sûr et après après sarah jusqu'au club
de films aux clubs de football comme son
club de football ils font référence
petit écusson sur le cash flow des
télécoms public enfin moi je me souviens
de ma fille j'aimerais mais je veux
moins chaude alerte âge ce qu'elle dit
mon voisin de gauche toute cette
synthèse pour moi c'est l'autorité qu'on
a perdu j'ai le sentiment vraiment que
weeds nationale à qu'on essaye de mettre
en place justement c'est à nouveau un
service national qui est la
manifestation tout cela c'est que ce à
dire qu'il ya plus disciplines y a plus
d'autorité il ya plus de militarisation
donc c'est un pari associatif en fait
qu'on est en train de faire alors qui va
te conseille de l'info survient aussi
d'occuper un mal à nos jeunes à se
rencontrer et à créer des dvd et des
masses moment là pour le coup je pense
que les réseaux sociaux il répondait du
coup on retourne dans un cercle vicieux
et la nostalgie de la troisième
république c'est celle ci c'est
finalement celle des institutions d
ordre de l'autorité de la discipline et
je crois vraiment petit à petit on est
en train de non seulement banalisée cela
mais en faire quelque part une une forme
d'exclusion plus il ya d'autorités
publiques discipline plus on exclut et
plus on rompt l'égalité alors que moi je
crois qu'au contraire c'était quelque
chose qui était naturel a servi de
vagues et une crise de l'autorité qui
est général mais aussi juste dans les
lycées une dizaine de jours
il ya un sondage très intéressant dans
le parisien s'est fait l'écho et qui
expliquait que vraiment la jeunesse
réclame est certes un certain retour à
l'autorité et surtout cook enfin
regretté l'absence d'autorité de l'état
parce qu'elle fait c'est incroyable
c'est vrai qu'il ya dix ans on n'aurait
pas parié là dessus et là c'est la zone
hesbaye et c'est probablement un peu en
lien avec les la façon dont la crise des
gilets jaunes et égérie c'est vrai que
les images sont quand même assez
choquant et même les jeunes moi j'en ai
parlé un peu en cours ils sont la rue
c'est quand même c'est quand même
curieux 20 août
il se passe rien on peut faire ça c'est
plus est c'est que je pense que plus un
état républicain va vers une forme de
tolérance n'est pas bon bol appliquée
par des finissants tolérance mais de
laisser aller de pair de l'autorité
mécaniquement le citoyen finit par la
recrée en votant pour les extrêmes
demandant un état fort qui quelque part
va finir par aliéné complètement la
république et on est un peu à cette
charnière là où il faudrait que la
république retrouve une position de
respect des lois voilà il ya une louche
de la faire respecter et non pas
aujourd'hui à une war et maintenant j'ai
deux cent soixante deux articles on
m'expliquer tous les cas d'exception et
de toute façon je suis sur le terrain je
ne fais pas respecté parce que vous
comprenez des fois j'ai des troubles
dans les quartiers ça va pas être
possible et donc aux rites et ça génère
quoi ça génère effectivement des voix
des extrêmes la volonté cet état fort la
volonté de et après tout sacrifiant même
la république et votons moins souvent
mais d'ailleurs je vais plus voter ça
participe aussi à cette espèce de
laisser-aller permanent il faut
simplement revenir enfin simplement
c'est facile à dire il va céder la
gâcher revenir en arrière c'est toujours
très très passéiste il y avait des
tendances très différentes qui
s'expriment on le voit valeurs que
mouvementée gilet jaune sur la
contestation de la police par exemple il
ya autant de gens qui disaient faut que
la police puisse faire son travail que
de gens qui disent comment les violences
policières c'est inadmissible j'étais
dans une manifestation interdite et j'ai
pris un coup de poing c'est je suis très
bien j'étais dans une manifestation
interdite et alors
mapa bienvenus on va pas bien et comme
ça mais non voyons pas dire qu'il y
avait des tendances très différentes
quoi va mais je me demande jusqu'à quel
point ça passe pas aussi par un
sentiment finalement ce sentiment de
légitimité peut-être création aussi de
petits cercles qui ne communiquent plus
entre eux et finalement je pense aussi
que la crise des jets les zones chez la
manifestation filets jaunes et
physiquement c'est la manifestation que
les élites craie finalement une forme de
microcosme que la société a l'impression
de ne plus pouvoir payer et ça je pense
que c'est ce manque d' écoute à la fois
c'est bon mois le le revenir à
l'autorité c'est une nécessité mais
restez quand dans la communication entre
ceux qui gouvernent et ceux qui sont
gouvernés
ça me semble aussi être une deuxième
valeur fondamentale que là aussi on a
tendance à oublier parce que du coup
comme chacun est dans son univers et
bien finalement on en oublie le sens
même de la démocratie en qu'en plus que
de la république c'est-à-dire de
finalement essayé de vivre ensemble et
d'apprendre à s'ajuster avec les
mouvements sociaux avec les
revendications qui peuvent apparaître
d'un moment où je pense pas être un
gouvernement garde son autorité par sa
pérennité ou par sa dureté
mais peut-être aussi par sa fonction de
légitimation et en apprenant toujours à
revenir à les hôtels et à la base
pourtant et comme vous dites c'est vrai
que il y avait aussi sauter ben brik est
un peu vrai c'est que on parle beaucoup
de république est et permet la
reproduction des classes sociales z n'a
jamais été aussi forte qu'aujourd'hui
c'est dans les grandes écoles c'est des
enfants de profs dans l'es20 voilà c'est
il ya moins d'enfants d'ouvriers qu'il
n'y en avait il ya vingt ans et cédera
donc c'est sa peau comme un problème à
problèmes d'identification aussi
peut-être que c'est ça aussi le le
manque de nos deux communes des monts
les hésitations unification la zone de
tout mais aussi des humiliations c'est
pourquoi les famines quand même
éducation c'est plus les familles j'ai
parlé d'instruction instructions vous
voulez voir un peu de foot
ah oui féminin de l'équipe 2 féminine de
france
c'était le 3 juin c'était je crois que
c'était clairefontaine on regarde plus
on en parle après parce que tout
tous regardent ça maintenant ah bon ils
ont fait beaucoup de bruit plus de 400
jeunes venus principalement de croissy
sur seine se sont rendus ce lundi matin
à clairefontaine pour un entraînement de
l'équipe de france féminine a rendez
vous programmé quatre jours seulement
avant leur premier match de coupe du
monde
j'aime bien ça me donne envie de crier
allez les bleus c'est bien si on les
voit pas tous les jours
c'est des professionnels allez les bleus
c'est pas tous les jours qu'on peut les
voir c'est
c'est les jo ce professionnel s'est
passé
c'est magnifique thème donne envie de
devenir pauvres des villes sélectionnées
par la fifa croissy-sur-seine recevra
les bleus pendant la coupe du monde pour
créer l'effervescence la commune a pas
hésité à affréter plusieurs bus pour
emmener des jeunes à la session d'avoir
la joie d'avoir des enfants heureux
c'est pour ça qu'on a accueilli l'équipe
de france c'est pour transmettre ses
valeurs de ce sport et d'amour et de
joie que l'on trouve ici dans le stade
après les tribunes direction les
terrains la matinée s'est terminée par
une séance de dédicaces avec les
joueuses tous ont voulu un souvenir de
cette journée de la compétition approche
plus plus agrandi pour iliad
effervescence au club c'est bien pour
nous c'est positif
les enfants ils sont pleins d'énergie
donc on en prend c'est bien ça fait
plaisir
en plus il ya beaucoup d'enfants et
c'est vrai qu'à notre âge
en bas on rêvait quoi de ça après avoir
rencontré les jeunes de croissy sur
seine les bleus fouleront pour la
première fois la pelouse du stade
omnisports de la ville ce jeudi si je
vois reprend l'entraînement à huis clos
avant leur premier match contre la corée
du sud
oui ça c'était avant le commencement de
la coupe du monde l'ancien général
contre le nigeria alors qu'est ce qui
s'est passé avec le var s'est lui même
s'était quand même meilleure équipe du
monde paraît-il l'équipe des bleus
contre la trente huitième nation
mondiale c'est pas très beau but par un
penalty qu'il aura trop de chance aux
citoyens comment était pas sûr direction
on a retiré deuxième fois les fautes
internet par exemple sous passeur vous
étiez passionné de foot volley seulement
par coupe du monde c'est pages en vente
ici
mais est ce que vous faites partie de
ces gens qui tout d'un coup découvre le
football grâce au football féminin
oui je voudrais se dressent encore un
peu différente
alors moi je découvre le football avec
les coûts du monde généralement avec du
coup les campagnes publicitaires autour
du filet
man formidable qu'il s'agisse de femmes
d'hommes mais absolument indifférent en
tout cas dans mon plaisir de spectatrice
on va dire je me demande jusqu'à quel
point finalement cette idée de mettre en
valeur beaucoup cette coupe du monde
féminine ne va pas aussi avec une
certaine politique du à chan meetoo de
cette idée de dire ni g peuvent
aujourd'hui la côte est et dans ce cas
là ça me gêne parce que justement soit
elles sont aussi bien que les hommes et
du coup je trouve pas qu'on ait besoin
d'en parler plus que cela soit on fait
ça pour une politique d'affichage et
dans ce cas là on leur met une pression
encore supplémentaires qui consiste à
être des héroïnes pour les prochaines
générations et c'est autre chose que ce
qu'on demande à des footballeurs roms
dont congo les gens adorent ça si on
regarde les chiffres d'audience et 10
millions des millions de disques
sélectionnés dans ces même plus que ça
profondément ennuyeux match de football
féminin pour l'instant et laisse non
l'inversé
et je pense que tous les gens qui
adorent ces gens qui n'aiment pas le
foot alors assez nerveux
maintenant que c'est un agrément en
entendant tout y est surtout dans tous
les journaux
les gens disent ah oui c'est moins
violent ah bah oui c'est moins brutale
et rapide c'est un autre convoi c'est
sûrement sympathique à regarder corde
pour l'instant les images versées
tellement déséquilibrée xv est
impressionnant mais il faut pas exagérer
quand même jouer ça n'a rien à voir le
foot mais ça peut faire découvrir le
football tout un tas de gens à faire
découvrir un sport ce qu'est le football
féminin qui n'a rien après moi je suis
hyper cocardier donc je ne souhaite
qu'une chose c'était lui le plus loin
possible si elles peuvent gagner la
coupe du monde je serai ravie et c'est
les yeux je les soutiens à fond mais
mais nous me fais laurent des ford et
ford et loire
je suis je suis déprimé mis tous ses
sages ou moins violents vous avez raison
sur la partie nitoo probablement que
gray néanmoins c'est la coupe du monde
donc de toutes façons de garçons sont
venus ils ont projeté de la même façon
les a vus c'est le maillot bleu ça se
passe en france et demande un produit
marketing et ça oui mais je pense que
pour une fois c'est un petit peu en
dessous de ce que ça aurait pu être dans
d'autres sports où j'ai tendance à john
holmes
alors là alors évidemment c'est moins
rapide ingrat mais c'est moins évident
mais n'importe où quinté plus solide en
même temps c'est plus fluide
la moitié des cas moins deux mois qui
suit le psg depuis que je suis tout
minot ses avoirs autant plaisir que
quand je vois le psg seul son cabinet un
ballon parce que voilà et jusqu'à
surnommer par 4 mi-temps oui mais quand
j'ai eu lieu qu'une fois les niches
furent donc je vois les ballons se voit
jamais sur 13 la contestation contre un
arbitre ça c'est quand même bien mais
parler des valeurs tout à l'heure c'est
sympa c'est de rentrer dans le magasin
on en a marre ça et peut-être que je
suis dans certains bastions
en tout cas moi j'ai vu que je suis
suspendu y est en tout cas voilà ce que
j'avais à dire moins de lui et que
certains matchs de l'équipe de france
après 98 enfin moi j'ai fait tous les
âges équipe de france stade de france je
m'endormais juillet lui la toussaint
donc après saint georges ou un peu et
charlène c'est j'ai entendu un truc mais
sidérant il y avait une
une ancienne footballeuse qui a fait un
bouquin s'appelle pas pour les femmes et
pour les hommes vraiment et qui étaient
là étaient outrés puisqu'elle dit le
sélectionneur a dit ah ouais c'est mieux
si vous êtes jolie enfin genre vieux
soyez un peu famille avec amis surtout
pas surtout pas qu'à choquer c'est
baisse de 2,2 frénésie dans l'autre sens
on dirait dans les halls jouer
ressembler à des fins non et on peut
être jolie je me fous tu faisais ce père
france ne s'est pas non plus cette
chaîne de télévision est partenaire
n'est ce pas d'un club de handball
féminin paris 92 ça n'a rien à voir avec
le handball léger parce que là mais on
est des humains sont autant je retrouve
un peu la même chose
vous avez raison ce que mes bons
exemples sa venue beaucoup moins que le
tennis mois le tennis féminin je
m'ennuie pas à nous tous ici je fais
exprès je me fasse ailleurs pas été
spectatrice qui nous regardent un an
plus tôt là je trouve le foot ça va
quand même essayer que les andes aussi
variés techniquement tennis près autant
qu'une compétition le curling contre les
femmes et ce ballet du kurdistan je suis
un peu déçu mais si on est parfaitement
objectif c'est vrai que l'équipe de
france féminine joue aussi bien voire
moins bien qu'une équipe masculine
régional bon c'est une ambition à long
terme de vitesse de jeu de dés de
d'habiter technique gp par contre ceci
ne m'interdis pas de dire que moi je
trouve passionnant de regarder le match
parce que c'est l'équipe de france est
la france
et ça ça me fait vibrer côté
la france va rencontrer les états unis
ça va être un match à enjeu ça va être
bien ça c'est vrai que jusqu'au 20e de
finale il ya des matches qui sont ses
revenus
un match de foot où il ya 13 0 on se dit
quand même un petit problème de
sélection les équipes c'est vrai que
c'est vrai qu'il ya un mélange de
professionnels damas
j'aurais pu faire il ya des traits le
monde à douze équipes masculines
ils ont véritablement ramer pour trouver
g car la très bonne nation masculine
comme l'argentine qu'ils soient en cours
des équipes faibles sur le plot féminin
enfin c'est vrai qu'il ya des la
meilleure championne de football féminin
la norvégienne elle veut pas venir alors
c'est terrible mais c'est quoi partie de
l'équipe également si on n'est pas assez
payés sur un des points qui consiste à
dire que si au moins on fait du football
féminin la même chose que le football
masculin il faut qu'on puisse avoir
autant de critiques qu'on en aa quand y
en a un qui a relevé son bus etc
je vois messieurs les états dans
lesquels chaud mais j'ai eu des crises à
la française continue aussi à lorp en
tant que femme je ne vais pas forcément
vu que tu as fait trop joindre mais sur
la qualité du coup si la qualité est
moindre il faudra le voir le dit et ne
pas avoir une fois en bien c'est
embarrassant à laquelle pourtant d'un
petit peugeot pression que le
commentateur sauts sont tout à fait
quand vous avez des bonnes équipes comme
l'équipe de france qui sont quand même
des joueuses professionnelles
il ya des critiques qui sont faites sur
tel ou tel joueur il faut notamment dans
l'esprit du public sur le fait que comme
ce sont des femmes et bien du coup il ne
faut pas leur faire la critique qu'elle
soit en bonbonnes que les hommes si
c'est le cas il faut le dire et c'est
pas grave almeria il ya quand même la
différence de traitement financier mais
c'est le comportement un côté le rappeur
black ops et 40000 euros
c'était 400 milles pour les hommes si
vous à dire à un enfant
meetic de marketing c'est à dire que si
on veut de l'activité du foudre est une
fille qui est remarquable qui est une
ancienne footballeuse c'est marinette
pichon
oui mais parce qu'elle commente les
matchs et l' or là c'est vraiment bien
parce que ce serait beau elle connaît
mais c'était une très bonne
footballeuses elle connaît parfaitement
la technique déjà elle fait vraiment
commentaire intelligent et je pense que
là elle est vraiment au dessus de
beaucoup de commentateurs pomme qui a
pris ce qu'ils sont très bons oui oui
elle est vraiment j'ai d'ailleurs toi ça
se fait une idée c'est très bien neymar
tout le monde
oui je le veux ce refoulement des six
mois oui joue les six mois les blessés
les pc parce que si ça lui il a déjà
perdu 70 millions c'est un peu comme non
nous irons tous au paradis il faut
vendre la maison quand les avions
il n'est pas blessé il faudra qu'on
trouve notre ribéry aussi parce que ça
manque aussi fait pour devenir une vraie
équipe en fait faut dire que globalement
il faut des gens on peut ainsi trouver
des stars aussi on va trouver mais ça va
venir
non mais par contre sur les déboires
d'une cassette vidéo niveau du mois
avait vu non non c'est vrai j'ai pas
benzema c'est pas bête des mac et sur la
cassette non y'a encore sur l'égalité
hommes femmes justement ça prouve bien
qu'on ne l'a pas acquise parce que les
scandales sur les femmes objets que ses
hommes peuvent se payer avec leur
salaire mirobolant scada existait pas de
l'autre côté
donc à ce moment là si on veut faire des
scandales et qu'on veut faire des
parallèles faisons aussi des scandales
de deux ans
la différence c'est qu'ils se dénoncent
pas et il supporte tant silence c'est
une question une question vénalité des
hommes se disent pas acheté par leur
politique
mais pourquoi pas je me sens très
politique déjà que le début petit retour
sur les élections européennes et avec
quelques est-ce que selon vous la grande
leçon des élections européennes est ce
que c'est que ce qu on a cru comprendre
ce qui se passait en 2010 et l'élection
des manuels vaincrons c'est à dire que
la fin de la droite et de la gauche pour
gouverner pendant 30 ans en france s'est
confirmée avec les élections européennes
je crois que le premier point la grande
leçon c'est que tout bien considéré
beaucoup de gens voter aux élections
européennes comme le pense un peu plus
que ce qu'on va plutôt ainsi elle
favorable après tout comme quoi quand on
parle d'europe les gens peuvent s'y
intéresser donc ça c'est mon premier
point je retiendrai le deuxième point je
retiens de rêve la mort de la droite et
de la gauche
ça reste une élection européenne c'est
avec les gens votent profondément pour
ce qu'il pense presque philosophiquement
plus que politiquement tout cas pour
ceux qui ne votent pas d'habitude donc
ça vient probablement un petit peu
faussé le résultat c'est mon deuxième
point will où la force des écologistes
absolument record tafer qui je le
rappelle ne devrait pas être un parti de
fait rend tout chose mais bon voilà
c'est comme ça donc on voit bien succès
que ça peut avoir parce qu'on a parlé
d'écologie quand même tout le temps long
continent paraît tout moment c'est bien
normal donc ils bénéficient comme si tu
étais et vague tout en rappelant qu'ils
sont deux points en dessous du mêmes
résultats aux élections européennes de
la fed avant et si l'on perd 2 2% par
rapport aux dernières élections
européennes
donc vous remettra alors après après on
en revient à un sujet qui fit transcende
toutes les élections c'est qu'on peut
pas gagner l'élection si on n'a pas une
tête d'affiché une tête de gondole star
est quelqu'un dont peu importe le
programme voir tout le monde d'être
saoul arrêté parce que je sens
je vous donne son parti pour gagner les
prochaines présidentielles vous
l'écrivez si elle se présente il gagne
comme quoi il faut que ce soit une femme
probablement donc ça c'est ma clé très
leçon et je vois bien qu'on n'y a pas de
stars on ne peut pas gagner
après emmanuel macron fait un score qui
est plutôt à mon sens honorable en étant
à mi-mandat alors puis qu'il gagne
demain avec un front national qui est
légèrement recul parfois oublié lui se
maintient de manière plutôt favorable
alors les détracteurs diront oui mais ça
représente que 15% du corps électoral
sont des élections précédentes et c'est
néanmoins le résultat fait qu'on prend
en compte que les suffrages exprimés
donc je trouve c'est peut-être victoire
pour le président la république
voilà la désagrégation de la droite et
de la gauche aujourd'hui on n'avait pas
de stars
ils ne sont pas mis d'accord le centre
était partout donc penser que c'est que
ça ben c'est pas plus profond que ça je
ne prends pas tout cas je prends pas ces
élections comme un jugement puisque les
prochaines ne permettent pas non plus
d'en juger et aurait été la sélection du
moment vraiment d'en juger candidat
présidentiel législatif suivant la
présidentielle ne faisant que confirmer
le score de la présidentielle et les
municipales c'est pas le sujet le
municipal ont réduit à 14 % par le maire
sortant donc savoir si ces élections ça
par contre c'est un impact majeur sur
les municipales on l'a vu que je suis
élu je dois et bien un problème c'est
qu'effectivement tout le monde a regardé
ses scores le lendemain tout cas le
maire sortant disons que donne la
typologie dans la commune ou la la
qu'est ce que je risque bon alors je
soutiens je soutiens pas je me rallie je
me rallie pas est ce que je vais pouvoir
me sauver sa de lélio 72 en plus de
réaliser un plaisir de revenir mais les
72 c'est ceux qui sont visibles aussi
tous les maires des communes moins
importante quand ils sont encartés ou la
problématique se pose ici aussi à 50
orne évident si vous grattez un peu vous
verrez que certains se positionnent et
que certains sont anxieux va donc le
test dernière leçon je tirais
européennes et après on arrête là c'est
l'impact que ça assure un positionnement
qui est déjà en cours pour les
municipales et des interprétations
parfois fantasmé qui sont tirées de tout
cela est du coup des positionnements
assez surprenant au sein de l r je suis
toujours chez l air mais soutient quand
même accro mais je garde ma carte
et son positionnement est fondamentale
elle est fondamentale y compris dans les
communes de moyenne strates dans les
strates de dire 15000 à 50000 habitants
dont on n'entend pas parler
bon il connaît nous parce qu on y
habitent et qu'on n'entend pas dans
l'appareil dans la presse mais où ceci
est fondamental y compris dans les
compositions des listes à savoir qui va
prendre des tickets de mas-grenier qui
va être repeints qui va être vert alors
qu'il était bleu la semaine dernière ou
rouge et et c'est vraiment un jeu comme
ça il faut le savoir c'est fondamental
fondamental à mon sens prêt je m'arrête
vraiment si on fait une mauvaise année
c'est à dire encore une fois ci ont
conser régions européennes sont un
emblème qui doit nous permettre de
décider ce qu'ils vont de prévoir car il
ya un marqueur fort des eaux municipales
ce qui à mon sens c'est une erreur
néanmoins c'est quand même un élément
qu'il faut à prendre en compte géant
vient le succès du président de
république évidemment aller re même s'il
n'est pas imposée auprès des locaux
c'est le prochain enjeu je vous rappelle
les locaux permet d'avoir éventuellement
des sénateurs c'est important c'est le
jeu de l erreur c'est de s'implanter
aussi je pense que ça touche plus le
microcosme politique d'ailleurs que les
électeurs réellement qui ont exprimé un
vrai suffrages pour les européennes et
je m'arrête là et bien que vous en ferez
peut-être l'homme at least rêve moi ce
qui me gêne un petit peu c'est que
finalement rien ne change
et c'est ça qui est inquiétant c'est à
dire qu'en fait d'ailleurs qu'on même
quand on analyse en faites
même quand on parle des élections d'une
façon générale on parle toujours de la
politique et pas du politique c'est à
dire des enjeux des grandes questions
qui intéressent les français et c'est
même d'ailleurs étonnant ce pour ça je
vous ai reposé la question pour de mêmes
grave de constater que finalement en une
égard aux résultats des élections chacun
se positionne en se demandant vers quel
parti il faut que j'aille pour espérer
obtenir un poste et je pense que c'est
de ça dont les français sont absolument
triste désolé on ya un ras-le-bol
général
c'est qu'en fait finalement ils ont ils
ont le sentiment que lorsqu'ils vont
voter ils ont pas de véritablement de
choix parce qu'en fait on leur propose
des parties des cartes des quelque chose
qui connaît ce qu'ils ont vu revu et
déjà revu encore prendre
et oui 34 l'histoire mais c'est sans fin
il n'y a pas eu en tout cas de débat
politique de fond c'est à dire que
pendant toute la campagne
même si son épouse était justement
imposé parce qu'à 34 nous a dit ceci
explique aussi cela et moi ce qui me
désole c'est ça et c'est que finalement
ça ça va dans le sens du coup du front
de marine le pen et aidé emmanuel macron
c'est que on arrive a cristallisé le
débat entre finalement le populisme et
le progressisme et donc à une espèce de
présentation binaire qui consiste à dire
finalement on a le choix entre parce
qu'en plus on caricature alex est aussi
le rassemblement national en faisant
passer pour un parti fasciste alors
qu'il n'en est pas un en disant qu'en
gros on a le choix entre entre hitler et
et macron et que puisque dans son parti
traditionnel ps ou à l'air finalement il
ya plus de destins possibles finalement
il faut basculer dans le camp
progressiste et moi je trouve ça
désolant parce que du coup le débat se
cristallise autour de deux partis
principaux qui se nourrissent en fait de
l'autre
c'est la cinquième république ça a été
la droite qui vont résister mais c'est
donc une vraie qu'il faut changer parce
que ce sont d'accord avec vous je pense
que le travail est vraiment finaude mais
ça va justement donner la possibilité
aux intellectuels de reprendre un peu la
voix et de discuter parce que un débat
il doit pas non plus être que politique
il faut aussi que de temps en temps des
intellectuels qu'ils puissent discuter
année les apporter des idées et
peut-être que là ça va ça va permettre
l'émergence ce qu'effectivement si le
débat c'est entre marine le pen et
macron bien c'est plus peu de débats en
fait on sait bien veulent pas et donc si
les intellectuels saisissent l'occasion
on va peut-être avoir des gens de voir
des idées et créer des bouquets
intéressant fait accorder des tribunes
dans les journaux on va redonner un peu
de sens arrêt mais au fond ce fait cela
entre au fond les goûts pour des sites
là en gros c'était entre les crocs
européens et les anti européens
il est quand même existants il n'est pas
aisé pages de ce tract hills pendant
trois jours les gens disent ah bah oui
mais le problème a confisqué de l'armée
c'est un débat quand même
mais mary bale s'est réduit à quoi il
s'est réduit à
pour l'europe ou contre l'europe c'est
agréable de se représenter mais c'est
pas c'est pas vrai parce que pour
l'europe ce n'est pas le sujet la
question de l'europe qu'il faut se poser
c'est quelle europe
de quelle manière comment ça ceci entre
les d'ailleurs il ya aussi une vision de
l'europe qui est défendu par marine le
pen
on peut détester ce programme et ce qui
est mon cas d'ailleurs quand j'ai des
contrôles l'oreille mais en fait c'est
pour une sortie de l'union européenne
pour rester dans l'union européenne avec
un schéma normal or tout le monde sait
qu'il faut changer de l'union européenne
et on ne sait pas comment on n'y a pas
de diaby n'a pas de vrais débats par
rapport à ça et c'est ça que je regrette
mois sur moi moi moi c'est notre vrai
débat de fond sur entendu parce que les
vraies problématiques sont les médias et
leur parut en fait si on prend les
programmes je vais pas parler du parti
auquel j'appartiens peu importe les
autres pour moi j'avais des différences
fondamentales entre le programme de
l'udps et y est le programme de macron
il y avait des points de convergence qui
est logique sont tous les deux pour
européen il ya des points de divergence
fondamentale sur comment réformer
l'europe qu'est comment comment revenir
sur les problématiques de l'unanimité
il y avait des vrais débats et quand on
prend les programmes le vrai sujet c'est
quelle report on en fait auprès de la
population c'est à dire si vous ne
faites pas l'effort de prendre des 33
programme pâte rendre aux braves avec un
n'avait pas levé tous met en avant les
vins programmes essentiels et qu'on les
compas et des points de différence la
question c'est à parfaire cet effort là
c'est un vrai effort sélectionneur je
suis je parte je vais les lire nos
médias la vraie problématique est
médiatique c'est des médias qui dresse
effectivement vous avez vous avez raison
mais si donnera mais je suis sans voix
je veux c'est une couleuvre est pour les
magiciens on a les médias cros mérite
mais selon l'interview des électeurs des
voiliers qui les dires de s'informer
ils le feront par 22 des barreurs
personnes vous vous demandez aux gens de
répondants 30 secondes c'est fini quel
est votre gueule folie's ovine l'europe
c'est mort de deux personnes que l'on
peut faire du fond ce qui était le cas
par exemple de françois-xavier bellamy
qu'il a pour le coup un discours de fond
dans le peu de temps qui lui était
imparti donc c'est possible quand même
mais c'est le rap a pas été payés parce
que c'est c'est une somme toute un peu
tout au bio politique mise à part on
peut on ne peut que constater qu'il a
fait quand même une campagne
intelligente y avait du fond il y avait
dans chaque fois vous êtes d'accord pas
d'accord mais il n'était pas dans la
petite phrase il était ce n'était pas
dans l'attaqué
c'était vachement bien précisons que ça
parce que je suis sa patte des payants
mon point mon poids c'est dédiant jeu
quand je dis les médias les médias c'est
que on a la vida con mairie que je
reviens ce point on est peut-être des
gens ici sachant pas ce que voilà on est
parisien on est dans du neuf en mai et
quand je dis ça c'est pour nous
caricaturer
je dis cela quand vous vous interviewez
votre voisin des gens qui s'intéressent
moins le seul regard qu'ils en ont parce
qu'ils vont ils n'ont pas le temps
humain de servir et de maçonnerie non
pas faire l'effort d'ailleurs les
programmes c'est ce qu'on en dit à la
télévision ou dans ou sur internet
est ce qu'on en dit sur la division sur
internet s'est il a amené un gadget il a
une phrase
fait faire à venir les gadgets en début
davis losc comme ready c'est ce qui
ressort et on est dans du marketing
politique on est dans de la com on n'est
pas du tout dans du fond ça ne pêche pas
que derrière je pense qu anna du fonds
mais les gens et je le comprends parce
que 20 personnes condamnées par les
genoux mais surtout les médias je veux
mais en responsabilité si on fait une
émission intelligente on n'a pas grandi
en moi mais mes parents on n'a pas
réduit parce que moi je vais fêter
vraiment en vacances et je pense qu'on a
réduit le débat à un pro contre un
maquereau est ce parce que je pense
qu'on oublie de dire c'est que emmanuel
macron avait dit on gagnera cette
élection et si on la gagne pas on se
remettra en question est finalement
première leçon pour moi c'est un
postulat de responsabilité politique on
n'a pas eu
c'est à dire que finalement si c'est du
projet du contrat macron il faut aller
au bout des choses et donc précisé que
ces élections quand même été perdus même
de peu par la liste qui était censé
gagner
est-ce qu'il faut se remettre en cause
et ce qu'il faut proposer des nouvelles
choses qu'il faut faire même ne
serait-ce qu'un discours de sortie ce
qui était normalement traditionnellement
le cas ici on n'a rien deuxième question
deuxième grosse leçon les gilet jaune on
attendait beaucoup de cette campagne est
de cette élection pour sa part comment
c'était postuler positionner l'électorat
par rapport à cette question là on a vu
qu'il y avait une ambivalence est à dire
à la fois un retour
et finalement aussi quand même pas mal
de retours vers un nationalisme et ça
c'est la troisième leçon c'est qu'à mon
avis on n'est pas les seuls en europe à
avoir donné du poids est encore plus de
poids même si c'est vrai que c'est une
courbe ascendante depuis au moins les
dix dernières années à des partis qui se
présentent comme anti partisans et
antisystème
et même si c'est insidieux c'est quand
même une augmentation du poids de la
parole de ces gens là qui moi
personnellement m'inquiète parce que
quand bien même on parle de l'europe de
quel projet pour l'europe de pour
l'europe de contre l'europe on a quand
même beaucoup de partis qui aujourd'hui
se présente comme prouvant que le peuple
ne veut plus de la politique et qu'il
est possible de la détruire de
l'intérieur et que malheureusement ces
partis ont du poids donc pour moi
la leçon à retenir les partis populistes
je parle des partis populistes et des
partisans
ouais non mais là la grande avancée
c'était 2014 s'est passé pas européens
de toute façon ça sera complètement
dissous donc il n'y a absolument pas le
feu au lac ça c'est une évidence
néanmoins en termes de poids un meilleur
maintien de la poussée énorme elle a eu
lieu en 2014 la police deux fois il ya
plus de vidéos de fracturation leur
programme et donc on a pour moi alors je
suis contre les théories du complot et
quand même déjà bien parlé beaucoup ri
ici mais je crois qu on s'ancre un petit
peu dans le caractère de parti de
gouvernement potentiel de ce type de
discours et ça c'est quelque chose qu'on
ne risquait pas il ya dix ans et qu'on
risque aujourd'hui après fermi vous
pinailler un peu parce que avec marine
le pen comme humain causant le même
nombre de députés les ont peut pas
parler parce que justement il ya quand
même vous avez quand même beaucoup de
raisons de voter contre le pouvoir en
place et d'avoir fait de cet engagement
un engagement de campagne c'est à dire
de si je ne gagne pas il faudra que je
me remette en cause n'a pas aujourd'hui
là autant de députés il a là il a déjà
fait de café ce quinqua promulguer cette
situation c'est la france a soumis twins
qui ont généré cette règle cette logique
laurent wauquiez s'est remis en question
maintenant c'est sûr mais je vais dire
mais il pourrait partir en bateau tous
les deux veulent orthez c'est souvent 10
x faut pas tirer trop de conséquences
politiques des élections européennes qui
étaient d'élections particulière mais
est-ce qu'on peut quand même déjà en
tirer une conséquence pour les élections
présidentielles à savoir que ça sera
compliqué pour les républicains ou pour
la gauche socialiste ou faux d'être
présent au deuxième tour des
présidentielles ou est-ce que c'est trop
tôt pour dire ça alors d'abord les
dernières élections nous ont prouvé que
c'est même trop tôt parfois appel ries
maire alain donc d'accord et puis j'ai
certainement pas de boulot mais on peut
changer l'arrière blancoise maintenant
demain matin j'aurais tendance à dire
que la messe est dite
d'un point de vue macro été élue femme
voilà je suis pas au premier tour mais
au deuxième tour je me vois pas comment
il en être autrement
mais il va se passer tellement de choses
il peut se passer tellement de choses
auraient par contre si personne ne
progresse et j'en viens à mon idée de la
tête de gondole s'il n'y a pas quelqu'un
qui émerge parce qu'alors surtout les
élections à vème république
je veux bien que le programme sont
importants et c'est excellent mais je
rappelle qu'on retient malienne deux
idées au maximum trois idées d'un
programme oui personnalité c'est que
quel soit gardée laisser le commandant
de la cie vous n'avez pas la personne le
deus ex machina
comment vous allez avait une qu'elle
vous concernant oui dont je disais que
je n'ai pas de conseils donnés
république je sais qu'elle est très bien
installé au fmi mais je pense que j'ai
dû voir si mme lagarde serait une très
bonne candidate
écoutez si valérie pécresse montant suis
très content qu'elle soit candidate mais
je pense que comines et celles
effectivement c'est parti je vous ai
bien peur d'une chef de file
il nous reste à peine une minute et
demie mais quel est le calcul de valérie
pecresse de partir des républicains à ce
moment là je pense que c'est à la fois
ou trop tôt ou trop tard
il fallait le faire mais bertrand
d'avant là pour se mettre en réserve et
d'ailleurs il me tient très bien ces
régions de france j'ai plus à du travail
et je vous travail qui est fait
il est vraiment locale en plus il doit
il doit avoir une forme de cohésion
puisque je rappelle qui a été l'élu y
compris que les voix de la gauche là
aussi pour pouvoir empêcher l'arrivée du
front national partir après vous qu'ils
étaient curieux plus ou moins obtenu le
départ je pense que c'est un petit peu
et d'erreurs à ce niveau là après
qu'avec son parti libre ça marche plutôt
pas mal elle ce sont dix mille adhérents
à ce que je peux en savoir ça m'a l'air
encore une fois trop tard ou trop tôt
mais encore une fois débloqué c'est très
clairement aux sahraouis je pense que là
on est dans une logique aux essais de
phase i bloc
je suis d'accord et patrice c'est
vraiment macro ont vraiment gagné
l'élection parce que faire le score
qu'il a fait avec la tête de liste puis
avec wi fi 3d donc ça veut dire prennent
normalement président aurait dû exploser
les tous les plafonds et là il ya quand
même donc non qu'il a c'est vraiment le
gagnant de cristalliser le débat entre
lui ou le chaos et d'essayer de
démontrer que finalement les partis
nationalistes seront du coup l'avenir de
demain et qu'il est la seule solution
j'ai perdu du temps mais cette heure-là
il a commencé je le rappel sous françois
mitterrand oui c'est pas des dossiers
l'aca depuis 40 ans était jean-marie le
pen avec les petites phrases qu'on
connaît mais c'est une belle c'est
différent et dragons jean lannes
mémorial de la shoah n'est ce coup pour
cette christian jacob a les moyens en
tout cas sur le tri pécresse peut-être
que c'est aussi une forme de signal pour
recomposer complètement de partie et je
pense que c'est exactement ce qui va se
faire à gauche également donc est-ce
qu'on va revenir à des ump dé gauche
plurielle et finalement des espèces de
groupes brontosaure qui vient voir un
petit peu au cabaret à l'extérieur des
parcs nationaux
on va en parler et il ya les municipales
qui se profile avec la pieuvre on va me
demander des changements un peu voire
tout a très certainement oui orageuse
peut-être sur saint quentin en yvelines
on verra bien mais en france je pense
qu'ils auraient effectivement quelques
changements je rappelle à plus de 90 et
89 % des maires sortants sont quand même
en général réélu mais il se représente
ça c'est juste pour qu'on sache sur quoi
on va s'exprimer tout le reste merci à
tous merci à tous les cas très bien
voilà une émission est maintenant
terminée mais on a beaucoup de sujets
pour la prochaine fois déjà a très vite
ne veut pas nouveau pas falloir
[Musique]